Narrator: In 2017, researchers tested
20 best-selling US sunscreens.
The good news is that 19
of them met FDA standards.
The bad news?
Nine of them didn't
meet European standards.
Turns out, different
countries have different rules
for what makes a safe sunscreen
and US sunscreens may not
be protecting Americans
as well as it could.
When we lay in the sun,
our skin absorbs two types of UV light.
UVA and UVB rays.
UVB light is higher energy
and can cause sunburns
while UVA penetrates deeper under the skin
and can damage skin cells
along the bottom layer
of your epidermis.
Desai: We know that UVB rays
are the rays that cause sunburns.
But UVA rays are the rays
that can actually cause
skin cancer so you actually
wanna cover the spectrum
on both of those.
I think a lot of people
get into a misconception
that I didn't get sunburned
so I'm not at prone
to getting skin cancer
which really isn't true.
Narrator: The biggest
concern with US sunscreen
is how much protection you're getting
from cancer-causing UVA rays.
For decades, FDA regulations
required that sunscreens
protect against UVB, but
not necessarily against UVA.
Meanwhile, rates for melanoma,
a dangerous form of skin
cancer, kept climbing in the US.
Then, in 2012, the FDA
updated its regulations
on labeling and testing so
that manufacturers must now
let customers know if its
sunscreen protects against both
UVB and UVA.
That's what the broad spectrum label
on your sunscreen means, for example.
And while this is a good first step,
there's still no regulation
on how much protection
you're getting from UVA.
So, there's no way to tell.
Desai: Here in the United States,
I think we need to be
cognizant of the fact
that when a sunscreen
says it's broad spectrum,
UVA- and UVB-protecting, that does mean
you're going to get
protection against those rays.
However, what it does not mean
is that it's going to
block out all of the rays.
Narrator: And that's where
US sunscreens fall short.
Desai: And I will say that
I do think we are behind
other countries globally,
particularly some of our
European counterparts,
in getting new sunscreen
ingredients approved.
Overall, there has not been much change
in US sunscreen composition
and what our sunscreens
are made up of in the past several years.
Narrator: The FDA has
approved 16 active ingredients
that protect against UV radiation.
But only some protect against
both UVB and UVA rays.
For comparison, Europe requires that all
of its more than 20 active
ingredients protect against both.
Desai: Right now, the American
Academy of Dermatology
and other organizations are
really advocating with the FDA
that they need to really
speed up the approval process
for new sunscreen ingredients.
Because it's with these
ingredients that we can probably
get even better coverage and
better protection and maybe
even get something that's easier to apply,
that's easier on the skin,
that doesn't have any harmful
side effects for patients.
Narrator: You can purchase sunscreens
from other countries online.
But if you plan on sticking
with American sunscreens,
look for the broad spectrum label
and don't buy anything below SPF 30.
Desai: The higher the SPF,
definitely the better.
But we definitely don't want
anyone going below a 30.
And think about if you're
someone who has a history
of a melanoma, if you use an
SPF 30, you're blocking out
let's say 98% of the harmful rays.
However, what about the remaining 2%?
That 2% may be something
that could be potential
of putting you at a risk down the road.